Okay. So now we've established that there are
two different versions of the ABO gene sequence at
this 796 position in the human population. And
it turns out that the variation that results in
[INAUDIBLE]
this amino acid position, codes for blood type A
in human beings. So if you have anything that produces
[INAUDIBLE]
here. This is associated with blood type A in
humans. But if you have the variation that results in
a methionine, or an M at this position, for
an amino acid, then that results in a B blood
type for humans. So we might call one of
these variations the A version, and the other one the
B version. But in genetics, we actually have a word
to describe these kinds of variants. We call them alleles.
An allele is just another word for variant.
Alleles are just variations of genes. The gene
is the ABO gene. But, we have two
different variants. We have one variant with an adenine
or an A at position 796, and another variant with a thymine or T at position
796. So we could call this an allele with an A that causes B blood type. And an
allele T that causes the A blood type. As
you can imagine we could have many different alleles.
We can change nucleotides all over the place, anywhere
we want and that's effectively producing different alleles, because
they're variations in the gene. So we're going to start
simple, and talk about one or two variations, one
or two alleles. But for any trait, any gene,
you can build up to virtually, as many alleles
as there are positions in the gene. What I've
done is listed the actual type A, blood type A
alleles, and the blood type B alleles. Changing from
a CGC to a GGC, a GGC to an AGC.
And I've done the same thing for the amino
acids that are associated with these alleles. The type A
alleles for leucine to methionine, glycine to alanine, arginine
to glycine, glycine to serine, uhhh the change from type
A to the type B alleles. What I want you to do
is tell me which of the variants, the genetic variants are associated
with the changes in the amino acids. I've numbered them one, two,
three, and four. And I want you put the number in the
correct box here, that shows the, the correct amino acid change with
the correct change in the genetic sequence here. Remember, use the genetic
code, I'm not putting it on the screen here because there's not
enough room, but you can click on a link in the instructor's notes
to, get a bigger version.